NATALIE BATALHA: Good afternoon.
The title of the talk, A
Planet for Goldilocks--
we're looking for planets
that could harbor life.
In fact, government agencies
both here and abroad are
committed to finding
evidence of life beyond Earth
and are investing
a lot of resources
towards that objective.
So I'm going to tell you
about one pathway-- one
possible pathway-- towards
that objective, which
is finding evidence of life on
exoplanets, planets orbiting
stars beyond Earth.
And this is largely
borne out of the progress
that the Kepler Mission has
made over the last five years.
Kepler is a space telescope
that was launched in 2009.
It's still up there.
It's still taking data.
But its level one
science requirements
are almost completing.
So I'll tell you
about that and how
it's changing the
landscape of this search.
There are actually
three pathways
for finding evidence
of life beyond Earth.
Two of them are symbolized
here through these images.
So on the left, we've got an
image of the geysers erupting
from the subsurface
of Enceladus,
one of the outer moons
in the solar system,
and so it represents our search
for life in the solar system.
Right now, we have no
indication that there
is other life in
the solar system,
but it could be lurking
in this subsurface ocean
on the satellites of
Enceladus and Europa.
It could be lurking on
subsurface Mars someplace--
maybe in a subsurface cave,
or some niche on Mars.
Maybe we will go to Mars and
we won't find life-- maybe
we'll find death in
the form of fossils.
But that in and
of itself is going
to be very interesting,
because until now, we've
only got this one
unique tree of life
in all its particularities.
And we want to know if
that kind of a tree of life
is ubiquitous in the
universe, or if it's diverse.
The other image represents a
radio telescope and the idea
that you can listen for
signals in the universe,
perhaps signals that are not
astrophysical in origin--
that is, they cannot be
explained by any astrophysical
body that we know of in the
universe, and therefore,
perhaps, are an indication of
some kind of technology that
exists out in the galaxy.
And this is the
famous SETI searches.
SETI stands for Search for
Extraterrestrial Intelligence.
We have the SETI Institute
here as our neighbor
in Mountain View.
But there are many different
SETI organizations.
Said there's a SETI at
Berkeley, at Harvard-- they're
scattered all over the world.
And this got a recent
boon by an investment
from the private sector.
Yuri Milner up the hill
has invested-- or committed
to investing-- a
sizable amount of money
to rent the Green Bank Telescope
to do this kind of search
for life.
But the third pathway for
finding evidence of life
emerged about 20 years ago.
I was a graduate
student at the time,
and I happened to be invited to
go to a conference in Florence,
Italy, because my adviser
built this instrument that
was operating on the Keck
10-meter telescope in Hawaii.
And it was there at
this conference in 1995
when a Swiss astronomer,
Michel Mayor,
announced the discovery of
the first planet orbiting
a normal star kind
of like our sun.
And here's an artist's
rendering of it.
It's not an actual image.
Everything you see is going
to be an artist's rendering.
We do not have-- well,
except for one exception,
two exceptions, which
I will show you.
So this is an artist's rendering
of the planet 51 Pegasi b.
It is a Jupiter-sized planet
orbiting tens of times closer
to its parent star than
Mercury is to our own sun.
It only takes about three days
for it to orbit its star once.
So it's a giant planet
orbiting very close.
In our own solar system, we
have the rocky, small things
on the inside, and we've
got the giant things
on the outside, beyond
what we call the ice line.
So we think of the giant
planets as occupying this space
in the cold regions
of a planetary system,
and the terrestrial planets
occupying the warm space,
and this very first example of
a planet we found completely
contradicted that paradigm.
Huge surprise.
Now, this is not the planet
we're looking for, right?
No solid surface, probably
doesn't have life.
It's being blow-torched
by its parent star.
So this is not a
planet for Goldilocks.
Well, what is?
What is it that
we're looking for?
I'll talk about two things--
size and temperature.
Or you could even think
of that as size and orbit.
And these are typically
the kinds of things
that we can measure when
we find an exoplanet.
Size might be in the
form of maybe mass
if it's a dynamical
detection, maybe radius,
or brightness-- those are
all indications of how
big a planet is.
Temperature is how
close the planet
is orbiting to its parent star.
So knowing something
about the planet's orbit
tells you something
about the energetics
and how much
life-enabling energy
that planet is receiving.
So both of those are
important if we are
looking for life as we know it.
Life here on Earth
is very diverse.
But no matter how
diverse, how weird,
how lurking in some
extreme environment
it is, every single life form on
Earth has one thing in common,
and that's that it's
carbon-based and uses
liquid water as the solvent
that facilitates the chemical
reactions important for life.
And so this is why
there's so much
emphasis on going in
search of the water.
So we're looking for
things-- for planets
that are at the
right temperature,
so that liquid water can pool
on the surface-- assuming
it has a surface-- and therein
comes the idea of size.
We want planets
that are not so big
that the gravitational force
is so high that it starts
to really efficiently glob
on a bunch of hydrogen
and helium in the form
of molecules and ices
that are so common
in the universe--
hydrogen and helium being
the most common elements
in the universe.
So that's what exactly
happened to the giant planets.
You build up a
core, a rocky core,
and the idea is that it
gets to a certain size,
and then it becomes very
efficient at accreting
on these hydrogen
and helium volatiles,
we call them, building
up an envelope
and creating a giant planet.
No solid surface-- by
the time you get down
to the interesting
stuff, the stuff
that our cells are made out
of, the pressures are too high
and it's going to be difficult
to form complex molecules.
OK?
That's the idea.
So on the other
extreme, down here
in the bottom right corner,
is a little depiction of Mars.
Probably too small.
Well, why do I say that?
Well, if you have a very
low surface gravity,
then you could lose your
atmosphere much more easily.
And in fact, that's probably
exactly what happened to Mars.
Mars has evidence of
water in its past.
This week, we
learned that it still
has something that's
kind of like water--
I can talk about that at the
end if you're interested.
But what happens is the
sun bombards these planets
with radiation, part of which is
ultraviolet and x-ray radiation
that breaks up water molecules
at the top of the atmosphere.
You break up those
water molecules,
and you've got hydrogen
and oxygen gas.
And the hydrogen, being
the lightest element,
is very easy to escape.
It escapes easily.
And so you boil-- literally
boil-- away your hydrogen,
and you're left with the oxygen
that has no more hydrogen
to recombine with, and that's
how you lose water over time.
So if the surface gravity
of a planet is really low,
that process is
really efficient.
And so although Mars had water
probably three billion years
ago-- in fact, oceans of
water-- today, as you observe,
it doesn't.
Right?
So we're looking for
that sweet spot--
again, for life as
we know it and life
that's remotely
detectable, not lurking
in some subsurface cave.
So here's where the Kepler
Mission comes into play.
Kepler, as I said,
is a space telescope.
It's depicted here cartooned
in the bottom left-hand corner.
It has a mirror about
1 meter in diameter.
And it's just doing
something really,
really simple-- it's measuring
brightnesses of stars
with exquisite precision.
And it has a wide
field camera that's
measuring about 190,000
stars simultaneously,
taking a brightness measurement
of every one of them
simultaneously once
every 30 minutes,
and it did so for four
years without stopping.
And without blinking.
And the idea is
when you build up
these brightness measurements
as a function of time--
and if you observe enough
stars-- the idea is
that some of those
planetary systems
are going to have orbits
that are aligned so
that the planet passes directly
between the disk of the star
and your telescope.
The planet casts a shadow
out into the galaxy,
like all planets
orbiting a star-- [MUTE]
And if the alignment
is just right,
that shadow will sweep across
the face of your telescope,
and your telescope will
perceive it and measure it
as a momentary dimming of light.
So that's what you see depicted
here with the green trace,
is this brightness dimming.
How much it dims tells you the
size of the occulting disk,
or the planet.
And then you keep measuring.
And you wait, wait, wait,
wait for it to come around
and happen again.
Now, you've got the
time between dimmings--
that's the orbital period.
Johannes Kepler
taught us in the 1600s
that the orbital period
is directly related
to the distance between
the star and the planet.
So now you know how
close to the campfire
you are-- that is, you know if
it's amenable for liquid water
to pool on the surface, or if
it's in this Goldilocks zone.
Just to give you
some appreciation
for how technically
challenging this is,
a dimming of light due to an
Earth-sized planet orbiting
a sun-like star is about
1 part per 10,000 change
in brightness.
OK?
So the analogy I like
to make is imagine
the very tallest skyscraper
in New York City-- it's, what,
like 80 stories
high or something?
Maybe it's taller by now.
I don't know.
Let's say 80 stories high.
And you're staring at
this-- it's nighttime,
and just imagine that
every window is open
and every room has a light on.
OK?
And one person in this
building goes to the window
and lowers the blinds
by about a centimeter.
That's the change in
brightness we have to measure.
So that means that we need
part per million precision,
exquisite stability
of our spacecraft
to move our instruments
in order to see this.
That's the idea.
OK.
So I want to give
you a bird's eye
view of what Kepler
has found so far,
and I'm doing it with
this animated plot that
shows the radius of the
planet on the y-axis
versus the orbital
period on the x-axis,
the two things that
Kepler can measure.
So you see points
being added to this
over time, some blue points and
a smattering of pink points.
These are all planets
that have been
discovered over the years
from missions or surveys
excepting Kepler.
OK?
So this is the sum total of
all of our knowledge of planets
up to the present day.
The blue points were
discovered with a method called
the Doppler wobble method.
I can talk about that
more if you're interested.
The pink points
that you see were
discovered with this methodology
like Kepler's that I told you
about.
We call that transit
photometry, because the planet
is transiting across
the face of the star.
And so even with
ground-based telescopes,
we did start to discover
planets with this method
around the year-- it was 2000.
The end of 1999, beginning
of 2000 was the first.
So if you look at
this diagram, you
start to see patterns, right?
You see a little cluster
of pink points on the left,
and you see another big
swarm of blue points up
in the upper right, a
smattering of other points.
There are some horizontal
lines for reference,
so you can see where planets
of different sizes would lie.
And this gives you an
impression that in the galaxy,
small planets like Earth
are actually really rare.
It also tells you that maybe
these very short-orbital-period
giant planets like 51 Peg b
might be really common, even
though we were very
surprised by their existence
when they were first discovered.
But now, I'm going to
add to this diagram
the planets that Kepler
has found over the last--
or in its four-year
prime mission.
I'll do that with yellow points,
and this is what it looks like.
You see the really
remarkable difference
that you can achieve
when you put out
a new piece of technology.
We just looked at the
galaxy with new eyes,
and the veil that was
shrouding our eyes
to the existence of these
small planets was lifted.
So what we saw before
was an observational bias
that came about because we
didn't have the sensitivity
to see them.
Now, with this
detection method, we do.
Yeah, that's a
really good question.
Let me repeat it.
He said, well, how long do
you have to observe before you
start to see planets?
And is the fact that
you have nothing
at orbital periods of
like 10,000 days because
of that finite observing window?
And the answer is absolutely.
Even now-- even though our
blinders have been lifted--
there are still observational
biases in this diagram.
All of the absence of planets
in this bottom right hand corner
is due to that
observational bias.
Kepler observed a patch
of sky for four years.
So in order to find an Earth
analog orbiting at 365.25 days,
you need to see it not
just once, but twice--
actually three times-- to
get a unique determination
of its orbital period.
So that means you need
to observe for at least
three years in order to see it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So your points were,
I guess, markedly thinner
above the Neptune line.
Is that an observational bias
that you guys understand?
NATALIE BATALHA: Yes.
I'm going to show you-- hold
that thought, because I'm
going to show you
something that-- I'm
going to try and
convince you that's not
an observational bias.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NATALIE BATALHA: OK?
All right.
The other thing I guess I should
point out-- where does Earth
lie in this diagram?
Well, it would lie
right around here.
So that's the sweet spot, right?
That's where we're headed.
You can see that we do
have a smattering of points
down there-- those are the
hardest planets to find.
In fact, if I drew a diagonal
that hugged this envelope right
here, these are the hardest
to find, below that diagonal.
And so we're just now
reaching the nexus
where Earth would lie.
You can see that NASA does
not over-engineer anything.
[LAUGHTER]
We will have another catalog
coming out next year.
And we might find a
smattering of new points
in that part of the
parameter space,
but I think this is
more or less what we're
going to have to work with.
I should also mention that the
yellow points that you see here
represent over 4,000 planets.
85% of them are
smaller than Neptune.
In the previous sample from
the ground-based observations,
85% were larger than
Neptune, so very different.
OK.
But Kepler was funded for one
very specific thing-- to answer
a very specific
question-- and that
is, what is the fraction
of stars in our galaxy
that host potentially
habitable Earth-sized planets?
The other way to
say that is, what
is the occurrence rate of small
planets in the Goldilocks zone?
So that's what we
have to quantify.
We will be a failure if we
don't calculate those numbers.
So in that sense, Kepler
is a statistical mission.
It's not about finding
the one Goldilocks planet.
It's about understanding
the demographics of planets
in our galaxy, of all types.
All right.
So this is a histogram
of the same distribution.
I want to talk a little
bit-- before I give you
the answer to that question
that Kepler is working to solve,
I want to talk a little bit
about the amazing diversity
of planets that
we've discovered.
Here is a histogram of
planet size from that sample.
And what you see
in this diagram is
that the most common planet
right now known to humanity
is a kind of planet
we don't even
have in our own solar system.
It's literally the
gray area in between.
You've got the
rocky-- or what we
think is rocky stuff--
down here in brown,
you've got the giants
over here in blue,
and this gray area
in between is where
we have most of the
discoveries, and we don't
have any examples of them.
What are they?
We don't know.
And so we look at these.
We have started to look
at these in some detail.
We have followup
observations on many of them.
Here's one example, a
planet called Kepler-10c.
Kepler-10c is larger than
Earth by a factor of 2.35.
We've actually also
measured its mass
with ground-based
telescopes, and we
find it's 17 times more
massive than Earth.
As you would expect, right?
It's bigger, it's heavier.
And then we get a
density of seven grams
per cubic centimeter.
But we've looked at
another one, Kepler-138d.
It's also bigger by
almost a factor of two,
but it has exactly the
same mass as Earth.
So what this is telling
us is that there
is a huge diversity
of compositions
amongst these planets.
And by composition,
I mean the recipe
for making a planet-- how much
of the rocky stuff versus how
much of the hydrogen,
helium stuff you mix in
is very diverse.
It ranges.
It's got a huge range.
So that's really
interesting to me.
I want to know, is this
something I could stand on?
Is this like a big super Earth
with more real estate and lots
of water, maybe a water world?
What are the possibilities?
Maybe the water covers
the entire planet,
but it's not so deep,
so you can still
have interfaces between water
and those other elements that
make life.
I don't know.
So this is just pointing
out that there's
a lot of possibility
to consider.
Kepler has also found a class of
planets that's orbiting, also,
10 times closer to
its star than Mercury
is to our own solar system,
but planets that we know
are rocky, because
we've measured
their size-- their radius--
but also their mass.
Mass divided by
volume is density.
This planet, Kepler-10b,
we know is a rocky world.
But it's being blow-torched
by its central star.
The star-facing side
has an ocean larger
than the Pacific Ocean.
But it's an ocean of lava.
Because the temperatures
on that star-facing side
are in excess of that
required to melt iron.
Not just rock-- iron.
OK?
We call these lava worlds.
How do we know that
it's a lava world?
Like I said, we
measure the dimming
of light as depicted here on the
left-- that's real Kepler data.
Every white point is a
brightness measurement
that tells us the radius.
We go to our ground-based
telescopes, the Keck
10-meter telescope
in particular,
and we measured the
Doppler wobble--
that's what's being
depicted on the right.
That gives us the mass.
Mass divided by
volume is density.
This cannot be anything else but
a rocky planet with pretty much
the same recipe as Earth.
AUDIENCE: How do you
know it's tidally locked?
NATALIE BATALHA: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: How do you
know it's tidally locked?
NATALIE BATALHA: The
question is, how do I
know it's tidally locked?
Because in between transits-- in
between the dimmings of light--
we see the light output
from the whole system
change by about two
parts per million
and then come back down.
What we're seeing is the day
side, night side, day side
of the planet in its orbit.
So I know that there is a huge
temperature differential--
thousands of degrees-- between
the day and night side,
and it's consistent.
It doesn't change.
Yeah.
That's a great question.
OK.
More extreme.
There are planets-- Kepler-10b
was orbiting its star once
every 20 hours.
This one, KIC blah blah blah
blah, is orbiting its star once
every like, eight hours.
It's so hot that it's actually
disintegrating before our eyes.
OK?
The planet is blowing apart.
How do we know that?
Well, because when we measure
the brightness very precisely
as this planet
transits the disk,
it doesn't have that nice
predictable shape, because
of that comet-like tail.
So what you actually see
is something like this.
Right?
It takes longer
for the brightness
to come back up on
the right-hand side,
because the planet has this
tail, this cometary tail.
I think this is
astoundingly interesting.
Because what this tells
me is I can actually
go to a telescope like Hubble or
the James Webb Space Telescope,
I can collect light
that's filtering
through that cometary
tail, and it's
going to leave fingerprints
of what that cometary tail is
made out of.
That gives me a direct probe
into what these planets
are actually made out of.
OK.
Kepler proved that
George Lucas was right,
although he got the stars
wrong-- the wrong sizes.
But planets do orbit
gravitationally bound stars.
So this artist
rendering on the top
is the planet Kepler-16b
that's orbiting
a G-type and a K-type star.
G-type stars are
these yellow stars.
K-type stars are
cooler and smaller,
and we depict them as
being more orange in color.
The G-type star would
be bigger, so we've
got an incorrect size ratio
here for these Tatooine stars.
But what this tells you
is that the planet is
orbiting not just one of them--
it's orbiting both of them.
So you've got not just one
star rising in the east
and setting in the west,
but you've got two.
Moreover, those stars
are orbiting one another,
gradually changing
position in the sky,
and they're eclipsing
one another.
So what we actually observe
is very complex and full
of information.
On the upper swath are the
brightness measurements
that Kepler takes.
And there are some
arrows to help your eye.
For example, we've
got blue-- if you
focus on the blue arrows, that's
a really huge dimming of light
that happens when
one star passes
in front of the other star.
And then, when that
star comes back around
and passes in front or
behind the brighter star,
you get the yellow.
So you've got blue,
yellow, blue, yellow,
you've got some blues
that are missing
because the spacecraft
went to sleep or something,
blue, yellow, blue,
yellow, blue, yellow, red.
See, there's a red in there.
Or a green.
The red and the green--
those are the planet
that's passing in front
of the bright star
or, alternatively, in
front of the green star.
And it's complicated,
because these two stars
are moving, right?
So if you've got one star
coming around this way,
and the planet's coming
around this way too,
they're moving in tandem.
The dimming of light is going
to stretch out longer than
if the planet happens
to be moving around
while the other star
is moving behind
in the opposite direction.
Now, they're going in
opposite directions,
and that dimming of light
is going to be short.
So that's a very rich
amount of information
from which we can ascertain
the masses of the planets
and also the masses
of the stars involved.
OK, these are Kepler orrerys.
Many of the stars
that Kepler observes
have not just one sequence
of dimmings, of transits,
but multiple
sequences of transits.
So these are multiple
planetary systems,
and what we have
learned is that there
is a class or an architecture
of planets whereby-- that's
a little bit different than the
solar system that we live in.
You know that planets in our own
solar system orbit in a disk,
right?
So you can think of
that disk as a pancake.
These planets that are
plotted here for you
are dynamically compact systems.
These are planets
that are orbiting
pretty close to one
another, so that's
why we call them compact.
And in these scenarios,
the disk is so flat--
if our solar system
were a pancake,
this would be like a crepe.
They're exquisitely flat.
So it's intrinsically a
different architecture
than we see in our
own solar system,
and that's a clue
telling us something
about how these systems
form, and how they evolve.
How they interact
with one another.
Finally, the Goldilocks planets.
I wanted to say something
about which planets--
how many of those
planets we find
are indeed in this
Goldilocks Zone.
Here's another scatter plot.
On the y-axis, we have
the surface temperature
of the central star.
Remember, stars come in
different masses and sizes
and luminosities.
On the top, we have
stars like our sun--
these are those K-type
stars-- and on the bottom,
we have the tiny M-type starts.
And so the green band
is the Goldilocks Zone,
where the energy you receive
on the surface of the planet
is amenable for liquid water.
So you can see that we
have a few dozen that
have been discovered
so far that are smaller
than twice the size of Earth.
So that's the sample that
we're really focusing on.
That's the sample that's
going to allow us to calculate
the fraction of
stars in our galaxy
that host small, potentially
habitable planets.
OK.
Let's see.
I can show you a
couple of examples.
This is one system-- one
of those Goldilock planets,
Kepler-186.
So you've got a cartoon
of the solar system
on the bottom that shows the
green band where the Goldilocks
Zone is, right?
Kepler-186 is orbiting one of
these really low-mass stars,
what we call an M dwarf.
So if you want to be in the
Goldilocks Zone for an M dwarf,
you've got to cozy
up next to that star.
So you see that the
green band is really
in a much tighter radius.
So the planet Kepler-186f,
which is the Goldilocks planet,
is orbiting with a much
shorter orbital period.
And there are people
who argue that that
is going to be
difficult for life,
because when you
get planets that
are orbiting so
close to their star,
they can become tidally locked.
Right?
They're more susceptible to the
ultraviolet and x-ray emission
that's coming off
of stars, especially
like M stars that emit lots
of that kind of radiation.
But then in July, we had
another exciting announcement.
It's now touted as the exoplanet
most like Earth, Kepler-452b.
Here's a split screen.
On the left represents
our Sun and Earth,
and on the right
represents Kepler-452b.
On the left side of
the star, or if you
compare these two
in the middle there,
you can see that
the stars themselves
are very similar in size.
In fact, they are
the exact same mass.
But Kepler-452 is older.
It's probably more like
six billion years old
compared to our Sun,
which is about 4 and 1/2
billion years old.
So it's a little older,
but otherwise very similar.
And they orbit with very
similar periods, Earth at 365,
and Kepler-452b at 385.
So they're receiving
very-- they've
got very similar energetics.
The strongest difference
is that Kepler-452b
is 1.6 times the
size of the Earth.
Is that important for life?
I don't know.
1.6 is kind of the
dividing line, where
you start to get big enough
that you start to glob
on this hydrogen and helium.
But the jury is still out.
It seems like that's kind
of a transition region.
So this could be an Earth
with more real estate.
I don't know.
Maybe an Earth with
even more water.
Maybe it's even more amenable
to life than our own planet--
I don't know.
OK.
So now I want to say a
little bit about statistics.
What is this answer
that we're looking
for with regards to the fraction
of stars that host potentially
habitable planets?
This yellow cone shows
you Kepler's search space.
We're searching out about 3,000
light-years along the Orion
Spur, so along a spiral arm
centered on the sun there.
And so I'm going to do a
little thought experiment.
Well, let me first show
you this histogram again.
You saw this
histogram once before.
This is just the number of
planets, and each of these bars
represents a different size.
Now, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to try and correct
for all of my
observational biases
in order to transform this
into the true fraction of stars
that are in the galaxy for
these same size [? bins. ?] OK?
And this will speak to that
question we got earlier-- who
was it that asked about-- Yeah.
Are these giant planets
really, truly rare?
So I do that correction,
and I'll just
toggle between the two.
See?
That's the bias correction.
So the small planets that
are really hard to find,
I have less sensitivity, so the
correction is larger for them.
The large planets, though,
hardly change at all.
That's because I have
100% completeness.
My survey is complete for them.
The statistics don't change.
So this scale tells
you that the frequency
of giant planets like Jupiter
in these warm interiors
of planetary systems are
an order of magnitude
smaller than for the
Earth-sized planets.
So this tells us that small
planets-- at least orbiting
within an Earth-like orbit-- are
much more common than Neptunes
and giant planets.
OK.
So what does that translate to?
Well, I'm going to ask
the question-- given
these statistics, where
is the nearest potentially
habitable Earth-sized planet?
How far out do I
have to go find one?
So here's the Milky Way
galaxy, a cartoon of it
depicted from the top down.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to scale the continental
United States to that size.
And here we are on the
shore of the Pacific,
and you're turning
east, and let's
look across the
continental United States
and ask ourselves, where is the
nearest potentially habitable
exoplanet likely to be?
And the answer is right about
there at the tennis courts.
It's very close.
The answer is three parsecs,
or about 10 light-years,
with 95% confidence.
So this makes the galaxy
seem like a smaller place,
don't you think?
This makes the idea of actually
going and visiting these places
a little more tangible.
Right?
It makes the search for life
seem all the more feasible.
And in fact, we
know how to do this.
We know what to do.
We know what
technology milestones
have to be met in order to do
this within the next 30 years
even-- to look at
these planets and look
for indications of life.
OK.
Another way just to
drive this point home--
I don't know if you
can see it-- but in
this little yellow bullseye,
in the very center,
there's a red dot.
Do you see it?
All right.
That red dot is
about 10 parsecs,
or about 33
light-years in radius.
This is a 3D
animation of the stars
within that radius, 10 parsecs.
OK?
There are about 350 stars
and like 250 stellar systems,
250 plus.
240 of them are like
these M-type stars,
these cool M-type stars.
About 20 are stars
like our own Sun.
Those are colored yellow.
The M dwarfs are colored red.
Like I said, that's 10
parsecs, or 33 light-years.
That's a factor of three larger
than the distance I just gave
you of 10 light-years, right?
So volume [? scales ?]
are acute.
That's a factor of 27 in volume.
So if there's one planet, at
least, within 10 light-years,
there's 27 times that in
this tiny little volume
that was just that
little red dot.
So these are the stars
that we want to target.
This is what we want to explore.
I would argue we want to go out
about another factor of three
in diameter, because I
want more yellow points.
I want more stars like
our own Sun to probe.
And there is where we're going
to focus our search for life.
And let me just highlight.
We're done working
up to the present,
and now for the
remainder of the talk,
I want to tell you a little bit
about my dream for the future.
But let's just reflect here.
All of this has come about,
and this search for life
has become within our grasp
just over the last 20 years.
Between 51 Peg b
and Kepler-452b,
we have grown
orders of magnitude
in orbital period, mass,
radius, radiation, energy,
all of these parameters.
We've gotten very close
to finding true Goldilocks
planets.
So now the task
at hand is to move
from finding planets
in the habitable zone
to finding habitable
environments-- to find
truly habitable environments.
And that will occupy us
over this next 20 years.
So let me say a little bit
about that future search.
This is NASA's portfolio--
just one government agency's
portfolio.
Kepler, you can see,
is here in the middle.
We've got two missions that
I'll talk about together-- TESS
and JWST, very briefly.
In the upper right
is a mission called
WFIRST, which I think I'll
skip over a little bit.
It's another
demographics mission.
It's going to speak to the
demographics of planets
not within an Earth orbit,
but beyond an Earth orbit.
So after that mission, we
will have a complete census
of plants in the galaxy-- not
a census, but demographics.
A representative sample.
And then I will end by talking
about what's listed here
as a notional mission and
we're calling the New Worlds
Telescope.
This is what is
being studied-- will
be studied over the
next five years--
as we develop mission concepts.
OK.
But first, TESS and JWST.
Just to remind you-- this
is Kepler's search space,
that yellow cone of
light that goes off
into the spiral
arm of the galaxy,
looking out 3,000 light-years
but at one patch of sky,
without blinking.
0.25% of the whole angular
area of the sky, right?
Just one swath.
TESS is a mission
very much like Kepler.
It's going to do
transit photometry.
But it's going to survey
the entire sky out
to like, 200 light-years.
So it's going to
look everywhere.
It's going to have to do that
with a step and stare approach.
It can't stay fixed
at one spot at a time.
It's going to have
to move around.
That means that it
will only catch planets
with orbital periods of
like, 80 days and less, so
short-period things,
but they'll be nearby.
And the reason
this is interesting
is because these
nearby stars will
be amenable to
characterization studies
afterwards with the James
Webb Space Telescope.
The James Webb Space
Telescope is the successor
to the Hubble Space Telescope.
It launches in 2018.
And the James Webb
Space Telescope
will be capable of
determining what's
in the atmosphere of
some of these planets.
So here's the idea.
This is the planet Venus,
transiting in front of our Sun.
If you look carefully, you can
see a very thin yellow line
that hugs the planet.
Can you see that?
Especially where
you have contrast
in the upper left-hand corner
against the black background.
That's the atmosphere.
Very tiny thin atmosphere--
the scale height
is like, five kilometers.
The total area that that
atmosphere intercepts is like,
1/200th the area of the
disk of the planet itself.
It's very, very thin.
So what James Webb will try to
do with the transiting planets
that TESS finds is it will
observe the planet when it's
in front of the star, it will
see the star light filtering
through that very thin
haze of an atmosphere,
that atmosphere will leave
a fingerprint upon the light
that the James Webb
Telescope will catch.
It will spread that
light out into a spectrum
and look for the
chemical fingerprints
of what the atmosphere
is actually made out of.
And here's a
cartoon illustrating
an example of that.
The James Webb Space
Telescope will do this
in spades for the
sub-Neptune super-Earths,
those planets in the
gray area that we
don't know anything about.
It's going to knock
that out of the park.
We're going to know all
about those planets.
We're going to know what their
atmospheres are made out of.
It's going to be great.
I don't suspect
that James Webb is
going to be able to do this
without a huge investment
in resources for the Goldilocks
planets that are really tiny.
For that, we need a
different methodology.
The planets are just too
small, the atmospheres
are too thin-- we just don't
have enough photons to be
able to see the signatures.
So for that, we're going to
need something different.
And imagine-- I mean just
think-- OK, here you're
getting fingerprint
from the photons that
happen to pass through this
tiny, little, narrow strip.
What if I could get all the
photons that are bouncing off
the whole surface?
Like reflecting off of
the whole entire surface.
That's a much
bigger area, right?
That just, in theory,
has to be easier.
And, indeed, it is-- if you
can take an image of a planet.
But you have to be able to
take a picture of a planet.
Right?
This is tremendously difficult.
So now, let me talk about
the New Worlds Telescope,
because that is the objective
of the New Worlds Telescope.
And here's the technical issue.
Trying to find a planet
orbiting a star-- like taking
a picture of it-- is
like trying to see
a gnat next to a searchlight.
The glare of the searchlight--
or the star, in this case--
it's 10 billion times the
light that's coming off
the surface of the planet.
So these planets are
literally lost in the glare.
In order to accomplish
this, we have to block out
the glare of the star.
It's analogous to going
outside on a starry night.
You walk out, you want
to look up at the sky--
maybe when you guys saw the
eclipse the other night--
and you look up in the
sky, and you see nothing.
Because you've got all
these bright streetlights
in front of you.
All you have to do is put your
hand in front of a streetlight.
Your pupils dilate out,
and you can see the stars.
So you just block
out the light source,
and then you can see
what's behind it.
That's what we're trying to do.
There are two ways
of doing this,
and we're doing technology
development on both right now,
and we've made a
lot of progress.
So I'm going to show
you two videos that
illustrate the technology.
The first one has
audio, so I assume
that the audio is working.
So I'm going to go
ahead and start that.
If I can find the cursor.
There it is.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-A distant star is
orbited by two planets.
One looks similar to the Earth--
the other is a gas giant.
When viewed from a
distance, the two planets
disappear into the
glare of their sun.
How could we ever find
these planets all the way
from the Earth?
By using a space telescope
with a coronagraph
to separate starlight
from planet light.
As the star's light passes
through the telescope's
large mirrors, it picks
up small distortions.
Diffraction adds concentric
rings to the image we see.
To reveal the planets,
first, the coronagraph
uses a mask to block
much of the star's light
and redirect the remaining
light to the outer edges.
A washer-shaped
device can now block
most of the rest of
the star's light.
Because the planet's light
comes in at an angle,
it misses the mask and
passes through the center
of the washer.
But when we turn
up the image signal
by collecting more
light, we can see
that the planets are
still hidden under blobs
of leftover starlight.
To remove these
blobs, the coronagraph
has a special
deformable mirror that
can change shape by using
hundreds of tiny pistons.
This can correct distortions
in the light beam.
As the mirror deforms, the blobs
of light as seen in the monitor
slowly begin disappearing,
finally revealing the brighter
of the two planets.
Afterwards, the fainter
planet also comes into view.
We can now see objects more
than a billion times fainter
than the star.
And if the light
from these planets
is passed through a prism,
we can spread it out
into rainbows of color.
But some colors are missing.
They were absorbed by gases
in each planet's atmosphere,
giving us important clues
about their composition.
The search for life
in the universe
has taken a new step forward.
[END PLAYBACK]
NATALIE BATALHA: I never
get tired of seeing that.
[LAUGHTER]
It gives me goosebumps.
OK.
That's coronagraphy,
a coronagraph,
where you put something
in the light path
to block out-- just like your
thumb-- block out the light.
The problem is that stars
create this diffraction when
they come into your telescope,
and you saw that, right?
Now, there are technology
hurdles to accomplishing this.
One, for example--
during that process,
where you've got the
pistons, and you're
adjusting the
shape of the mirror
and making all of these
subtle corrections--
during that process, you
need pointing stability down
to like a picometer.
Really, really exceptional
pointing stability.
So that's one technology hurdle.
Another technology hurdle
is that well, OK, fine--
but you still need to
collect enough photons.
These things are
really, really dim.
I need a huge
photon bucket, which
means a big, gigantic mirror.
The only way we're going to get
a big, gigantic 10-meter dish
mirror out into space is by
making it segmented and folding
it up into your rocket ferry.
Right?
The problem is that
when you do that,
when you make a
segmented mirror,
all of that diffraction that
you saw that makes the rings
is different.
So we have to learn how to do
this with segmented mirrors.
We have to learn how to
achieve that picometer
stability in the pointing, in
the thermal sensitivity, all
of that.
It's really going
to be challenging.
Now, you can simplify
that if you figure out
a way to hold a giant thumb out
into space instead of putting
it in your optical path.
If I can put a giant
thumb out in space,
it's going to make
it much more simple.
I'm taking it out
of the optical path,
and I don't have to worry
about that wavefront control.
And we're trying that.
This is called
starshade technology,
and this is the next video.
Here, there's no audio.
What you're seeing is
a probe class starshade
that is unfurling and
creating a shape that
looks like a sunflower.
It has that special sunflower
shape because of the way
that we want it to
control diffraction.
But the idea is
that you're going
to fly this thing independently
some tens of thousands
of kilometers away, so
that it gets really tiny
and perfectly blocks
out the starlight.
You're going to have
another space telescope that
is doing telemetry or
metrology to communicate
with the starshade and get it
perfectly pointed and aligned,
and hold it there, steady--
like a giant thumb up in space--
so that you can see the
planets it lost in the glare.
Two different technologies
that each have their advantages
and disadvantages.
The disadvantage of
this one, although it
made the optics really
simple-- much more simple--
the problem is that it's tens
of thousands of kilometers away,
and now you want to
point over there and look
for a planet over
there, and you've
got to sit there and wait while
the starshade makes the journey
from one place to another.
So you lose a lot of time.
But if the telescope can stay
observing something else--
making other astrophysics
contributions
while you're waiting
for that slew time--
maybe that's
something worth doing.
So those are the
two technologies.
I wanted to show you that,
indeed, we've already done this
from the ground, albeit not
for small, Earth-sized planets
in the Goldilocks Zone.
There was an announcement
just about a month ago--
the first planet
discovered by an instrument
called the Gemini
Planet Imager, GPI.
The Gemini Planet Imager.
Here is the image
from that telescope.
You see the concentric rings.
That's the Eri pattern due
to the diffraction-- just
the remnant Eri pattern.
But here's the planet, 51 Eri b.
This was another
system-- I can't remember
which instrument discovered it.
I think Keck-- and here, you
see one, two, three planets.
But what you also see, because
we've been observing this
for so long, is you see
the planets actually moving
in their orbits.
Now, you've got some
dynamical information
to tell you something about
the masses of these planets.
So this is really
promising, right?
This looks great.
But just one caveat
that what you're seeing
there are planets larger than
Jupiter, younger than Jupiter,
so they're hotter than
Jupiter, and they're
orbiting tens of times
further out than Jupiter.
So here is what our own
solar system would look
like with such an instrument.
Actually, a better instrument.
And Jupiter and Saturn,
OK, we can do that.
What we want to achieve,
though, is find the Earths there
in this annulus.
So that's why it requires
a space-based telescope
to get above the atmosphere.
It also requires a very
large light bucket,
because these things
are going to be faint.
And so this is what
we're talking about.
We've got the Hubble down here--
dwarfed in the lower left-hand
corner-- the Hubble 2.4-meter
telescope next to Goldilocks
there.
James Webb, its successor,
at 6.5 meters in diameter.
But what we are proposing--
our moonshot right now--
is a 10- to 12-meter
class telescope that
will have the capability
of seeing this tiny annulus
and collecting enough
photons so that we
can search for biomarkers.
AUDIENCE: How cheaply
can you actually build
a telescope like that?
NATALIE BATALHA: What's that?
AUDIENCE: How cheaply
can you actually build
a telescope like that?
NATALIE BATALHA: How
cheaply can you build it?
The good news is the cost
per unit collecting area
of telescopes is going down.
So they do get cheaper
as you learn more
and as you build them.
But they're still
extraordinarily expensive.
So if I were to project out a
couple of decades as to when
we would start to
build this thing,
I would guess-- I could posit a
guess that it would cost about
the same as the
James Webb Telescope
does now, something on the
order of $5 to $10 billion.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, did I
shock you there?
[LAUGHTER]
Come on, this is Google.
OK.
Let's see.
Why such a large telescope?
I can answer those questions
if you're interested.
Just to say that what
we really want to do,
as you saw in the video,
is take a spectrum
and look for the presence
of all of those gases
that are emitted by complex
life forms on planet Earth
as they metabolize food into
energy-- things like methane,
oxygen, respiration
processes, all of those things
that are indication
not just of a planet
but of an actual living world.
Again, this is possible.
It's not limited
by what we know,
it's not limited by technology--
it's just simply limited
by resources.
So with enough time, we
will accomplish this.
Could be maybe not
in my lifetime,
but certainly in my children
or grandchildren's lifetime,
I think that this is
going to happen-- where
one day, soon, we will know for
certain that life does or does
not exist beyond Earth.
So that's where we're headed.
And I'll end with the
beautiful retro travel posters
that JPL created for these
worlds of our imagination
that actually do exist, just
with quite not so much color.
Yet.
All right, thank you very much.
I'd be happy to take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I recently
read that you
should be able to detect the
glare of a water-covered planet
going in front of the star
that they orbit around.
Would Kepler be able to see
this, or any of the satellites
that are proposed?
NATALIE BATALHA: So
to detect the glare--
so when you say glare,
to me you're implying
reflected light.
So light that's
coming from the star
is bouncing off of a
shiny surface right?
And we see that.
And so the question is, is
that possible with Kepler?
We do see some phase functions
as planets are orbiting around.
The kind of specular reflection
that you're talking about
would happen at precise moments.
We see these kinds
of phase functions
for mostly giant planets
that are heated on one side
compared to the other,
so I don't know.
I'm not aware of any
such a detection.
We will do this in the future.
I think that our best bet
is to do the transmission
spectroscopy between
TESS and JWST,
see the light come
through the atmosphere--
so you're not talking
about a glare,
you're talking
about transmission--
and hopefully see
evidence of water vapor.
Whether or not we'll have
the kind of situation--
I'm not even sure water
worlds exist in entirety,
but certainly oceans-- the
kind of specular reflection
that happens quickly when
you're just at the right angle,
I think, is going to be
very difficult to find.
Yeah.
Just thinking out loud here.
AUDIENCE: Direct
imaging-- is it easier
to just do the reflected
light from the star,
or the transmission
from the planet
based on its temperature?
NATALIE BATALHA: OK.
So the direct image emissions
are reflected light off
of the surface, but
they can also be--
and this is where
I thought you were
going with that question-- they
can also be thermal emission.
That is, the warmth
of the planet
itself-- like in the case
of the multi-planet system
from direct imaging
that you saw--
that was enabled by the
fact that the planets are
young and hot, so they're
emitting thermal radiation
and you're seeing
that emission as well.
AUDIENCE: Well, and the contrast
between the star and the planet
would vary based on which
wavelength you're looking at--
NATALIE BATALHA: Absolutely.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: --and based
on the temperature, too.
NATALIE BATALHA: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So if
it would be easier
to look for really hot
planets close in because--
NATALIE BATALHA: Ah.
I see.
AUDIENCE: They're emitting
a radiation length
that the star doesn't emit
at as much as it normally--
NATALIE BATALHA: Yeah, but
see, when they're close in,
you have a resolution problem.
One of the other reasons why
you need a big telescope even
to see the Goldilocks
Zone is because you're
trying to separate-- you're
trying to be able to resolve
a planet next to a star, right?
And so resolution is
proportional to the diameter
of the telescope.
So the closer in
you want to see,
the higher resolution
you're going to need,
and we're already really
hard-pressed to do that
for an Earth out at 365 days.
So if you want to do something
for planets that are even
closer, you have two choices.
Either you do
transmission spectroscopy
in the way that
you've mentioned--
but that, of course, only works
if you have the right geometry.
Or the other
alternative-- and I think
this is going to
happen-- on the ground,
we are already building
30-meter telescopes, so
telescopes that are three
times bigger in diameter,
27 times more collecting area,
and you get the same benefit
with resolution.
So now you have the
possibility of seeing
the habitable zone of the M-type
stars, which are closer in.
You can't do that with a
10-meter class telescope
even in space, because you
just don't have the resolution.
But with the 30-meter
telescopes from the ground--
if we can work out the rest
of the technology challenges--
we might be able to do it.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
the orientation.
Do you find that it's
typically consistent
that we tend to be with
the disk of the galaxy,
or are they pretty
randomly oriented?
NATALIE BATALHA: Yeah, that's
a really good question.
The question is, do we have
any preferential geometry
in the galaxy with
these orbital planes?
And the answer's no-- that
they're all cattywampus,
randomly distributed.
AUDIENCE: Would there be any
disadvantage, or advantage
or disadvantage, to something,
a telescope based on the moon,
so you have something
solid to put it on
and still no atmosphere?
NATALIE BATALHA: Is
there an advantage
to building a
telescope on the moon?
AUDIENCE: I'm
thinking like, instead
of having to put a
satellite out far away,
you might be able
to put a relatively
small thing on a mountain
a few kilometers away.
NATALIE BATALHA:
Yeah, which is kind
of what we're doing on the Earth
to test the technology, where
we're going out into the
desert and setting up
systems like that.
I don't know.
That's a really good question.
There are other
challenges you have
to think about when you
go to the moon-- first
of all, getting supplies there,
of course, because you're going
to have to make multiple trips.
But also the dynamics
on the moon--
you've got a lot of dust, right?
And so I know that one of the
biggest technological hurdles
to building
telescopes on the moon
is just the amount of dust.
And we've got the regolith,
which has this very fine dust.
In fact, if you do hiking
in California, because
of the drought,
the ground-- God,
I'd hiked up the
[? Ridge Lane ?] the other day
for the eclipse, and it was
like I was walking on the moon.
It was like, poof!
Poof!
So if you have even
lower surface gravity,
that dust is going to loft.
It's going to get
into your electronics.
It's going to be a mess.
So, yeah.
Nobody seems to be thinking
seriously about that,
but that doesn't
mean that it's--
AUDIENCE: What's the
status of Kepler today?
I know that with its
reaction wheels failing,
but there was some
back up plan in mind.
NATALIE BATALHA: Yeah.
Thanks for asking that.
Maybe I'll go ahead and
back up a little bit.
So the question is, what is
the status of Kepler today?
A few years ago-- sorry.
This is not very
efficient, is it?
Well, several years
ago, Kepler lost
one of its reaction wheels.
And so the reaction wheels are
these like gyroscope things,
that-- there are three of
them, one for each axis--
and they keep the telescope
pointing very stably.
So there was some redundancy
built into the spacecraft--
there were four.
You only need three,
because there's
three axes you can rotate about.
And so we had four, we
had some redundancy.
We lost one.
No problem, we've got three.
But then, a couple
years ago-- in fact, it
was on my birthday-- I was just
about sitting at my birthday
lunch, and I got
the phone call-- we
lost a second reaction wheel.
So now, we were
down to two-- that
meant Kepler was
spinning about one axis.
We had no control.
OK?
So for me, I was like,
well, OK, we already
completed our baseline
mission-- we'd already
collected four years
of data, and that
was our baseline
mission, so I'm good--
but it was a disappointment.
But the engineers at Ball
Aerospace were very clever.
And what they did
was they recognized
that there is an axis
of symmetry built
into the spacecraft itself.
And so-- well, let me
back up for a second.
What is it out in space that
make the telescope spin?
The answer is radiation
pressure from the Sun.
So you're literally
being pushed on by light.
It's very small,
but it accumulates.
So they recognized
that they could
utilize this axis of
symmetry if they lined it
up with the vector pointing
towards the radiation
pressure towards the Sun,
and they did that perfectly.
It would be like pointing
a boat directly upstream.
If you balanced it, you would
neither yaw to the right
nor to the left-- you
would stay the course.
And that's what they did.
So that axis of symmetry happens
to be in an orientation that
puts the telescope observing
along the ecliptic plane
of the solar system.
So it limited the
amount of places
where we could
point and observe.
It also meant that we could
not point the telescope
to the baseline patch of
sky that we were observing,
but it actually opened
up the possibility
of this whole entire
new thing called
K2, which is Kepler's
second mission
but actually named
after the mountain, K2.
And so K2 is looking
at these patches of sky
along the ecliptic,
and you see it there
traced out as this
sine wave with regards
to the plane of the
galaxy, which you see there
as a flat image
across the screen.
So it's going to observe each
of these patches of sky--
it's been doing that
already for over a year now
with great success.
So it's kind of like a step and
stare approach, more like TESS.
And we're finding lots of
planets in these patches,
including some planets that
are-- oh, that pink part just
shows you where
in the sky we get
to look relative to the
Kepler field of view
during the baseline mission.
When you add up all the fields
that we will observe over
a few years, maybe four years,
that adds up to about 4%
of the sky instead of 0.25%.
So it's great, and we're finding
planets that are actually
really close by, like this
three-planet system that's
just 100 light-years away.
So it's doing good stuff.
And I think it's
actually going to find
some really good candidates for
the James Webb Space Telescope
to observe when it
launches in 2018.
AUDIENCE: How long is the
mission expected to continue?
NATALIE BATALHA: How long
is it expected to last?
So there is a hard constraint,
and that's the fuel.
There's a fuel on board
the spacecraft that
does some thruster firings to
change position, and that does
have a finite lifetime.
But I think it'll
easily last four
years in this configuration.
AUDIENCE: So this is
obviously a lot of data
you guys are collecting.
How much [INAUDIBLE]?
NATALIE BATALHA: How much
data is left to be analyzed?
We're still actually
even working
on the data from the baseline
mission-- that first four
years between 2009 and
2013-- because we're
improving the pipeline
that does the analysis.
So we'll get some more
discoveries from that data.
But we're wrapping that up.
That's due to finish
by September of 2017.
So we've got about a
little less than two years
to finish up the
analysis of that data.
That's sad.
The data sits in
the public archives,
and scientists will be analyzing
that data for decades to come,
because it's such
a rich data set.
Kepler's level one
science requirement
is just to compute
the fraction of stars
with planets of
certain properties,
but there's a lot
of other things
you can do with this data to
characterize planets and learn
about different architectures
and oddball cases,
and all kinds of things.
AUDIENCE: What is the
process for scientists
to get access to that data?
NATALIE BATALHA: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What is the process
by which scientists get access
to that data?
NATALIE BATALHA: Oh, you
could do it right now
with your phone.
It's there.
The NASA Exoplanet
Archive is one repository,
and then the
Multimission Archive
at the Space Telescope Science
Institute is another archive.
So yeah, it's all
publicly available.
Anybody could play with it.
Well, thank you very
much for your time.
Any other questions?
[APPLAUSE]